[Musique]
on est vraiment content de vous revoir
et je veux vous demander juste comment
vous allez après cette année de guerre
c'est une année difficile mais moi j'ai
appris beaucoup de moi-même de mes
propres capacités je pense que c'est la
même chose pour plusieurs de de
supprimer pour toute la nation
ukrainienne et quel est l'état d'esprit
des
Ukrainiens aujourd'hui vous diriez
on fait tout pour avoir cette victoire
parce qu'il doit y avoir une certaine
fatigue quand même oui c'est la fatigue
c'est
j'en ai marre c'est
peut-être une certaine tristesse une
certaine dépression à une déprime mais
on en a pas le droit à ce moment de se
laisser faire par ses émotions on se
regroupe on se mobilise et on continue
de
d'exister d'exister et de nous défendre
et de travailler
n'importe dans quelle
moyen pour pour rapprocher cette
victoire
vous vivez avec ces sirènes vous vous on
s'habitue à vivre dans la guerre vous
savez j'ai passé les dernières je pense
deux ou trois semaines
hors de l'Ukraine et quand j'étais
revenue et
le premier nuit il y avait les sirènes
j'ai sorti sur le balcon et c'est très
étrange mais le son ça m'a dit bon tu es
vraiment à la maison c'est juste un
aspect de devis normal à ce moment à qui
et je dirais que de venir habitué à ces
choses dangereuses périlleuse comme les
attaques aéréales comme les sirènes qui
marque les attaques
c'est pas pour vous ça du tout on
recense déjà plus de 60 000 crimes de
guerre on a beaucoup entendu parler de
la torture des viols mais il y a
également des enfants des enfants qui
sont pas épargnés il y aurait 16 000
enfants
Ukrainiens qui auraient été déportés en
Russie qu'est-ce que ça nous dit de la
stratégie des Russes c'est à dire que
les Russes sont en train de commettre le
crime de la génocide contre les
Ukrainiens parce que exactement cela
retirez les enfants de leur famille
retirer les enfants de leur pays séparer
les familles
c'est sont tous des signes du crime de
génocide la communauté internationale a
une responsabilité de prévenir le crime
de la génocide et on ne l'a pas fait le
crime de la génocide et entrain de se
dérouler à ce moment en Ukraine et les
Russes sont responsables de cela
quand on se promène vers l'est vers la
ligne de front on voit toutes ces villes
détruites des villages entiers il y a
plus une maison qui tient debout et on
se demande comment est-ce qu'après ça va
pouvoir être reconstruit pour moi
la destruction c'est c'est pas juste la
l'importance et le besoin de trouver
l'argent pour
reconstruire les maisons les écoles les
autoroutes pour moi ce sont des vies
humaines qui ont été détruites donc ces
maisons il y avait des gens qui
habitaient il y avait des familles qui
habitaient où sont ces familles ils sont
soit mort ou ils sont ils ont dû
déménager 7 millions de déplacés
hors de l'Ukraine en Europe au Canada
aux États-Unis et partout au monde et
encore 8 millions de déplacés en Ukraine
des Ukrainiens qui ont dû quitter leur
maison à l'est de l'Ukraine tout au long
de des frontières de la guerre de combat
et qui ont dû déménager soit acquis soit
plus loin vous vous êtes une députée de
l'opposition au début de la guerre vous
avez appuyé volo diverski après tous ces
sacrifices après tout ce qui s'est passé
depuis un an est-ce que c'est encore le
cas et absolument vous savez le
Président il a
montré
son dédication à son pays à son peuple
c'était très clair il n'a pas pris le
taxi il a comme les américains lui
proposait de faire et pour moi c'est
c'est un grand signe qui me dit que
c'est vraiment un président
ukrainien qui travaille pour l'Ukraine
pour le bien de son peuple pour le bien
de son pays avec ce président là je
crois vraiment la victoire est-ce que
vous pensez qu'après une réconciliation
entre les deux pays et maintenant
possible
ça sera après la victoire on devrait
penser à ça parce que toute façon les
Russes se sont nos voisins
ils vont pas tout d'un coup tous
disparaitre
bon il reste donc on devrait trouver des
moyens comment comment est habiter avec
mais avant que ça commence on doit
entendre un simple pardon pardonnez nous
on doit avoir des excuses on doit avoir
comme avec les réparations pour les
bâtiments on doit avoir ce sentiment de
la nation russe qu'ils ont fait tort
qu'ils ont fait mal est-ce que les
Ukrainiens est-ce que leurs sentiments
ont changé est-ce que tout ce qui s'est
passé fait qu'ils sont
plus résilient encore
quand il y a un problème tel que la
guerre ça c'est un grand grand problème
pour survivre on s'unit donc il y avait
eu cette unité totale à un niveau
national avec cette unité on a découvert
des valeurs qui ont été toujours là je
pense mais ils ont été redécouvertes et
une deux c'est vraiment cette résilience
après tous les sacrifices les gens ils
doivent se dire on peut pas arrêter
maintenant il faut aller jusqu'au bout
quoi parce que on n'a pas d'autre choix
on a qu'une seule Ukraine
merci beaucoup merci